we are told a student hangs blocks with
different masses from a pulley of mass m
and radius r and releases them from rest
the student measures the time of the
fall t
and the magnitude of the angular
velocity omega sub f when the block
reaches a distance d below the axle
there is considerable friction between
the axial and pulley
which of the following plots could show
the student's measurements as a function
of the applied torque on the pulley so
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own
alright so let's first understand what
these axes are and then we'll talk a
little bit about what's going on with
this mass pulley system
so on our horizontal axis here we have
our applied torque now where is the
applied torque in this system well
you're going to have some mass here and
we assume we're on a planet or probably
on earth so you're going to have gravity
pulling down on this so you're going to
have the force of the weight of this
object pulling down and we know that
this has radius r
so that force times that radius is going
to be the applied torque and of course
the more mass you have the more weight
you're going to have and you're going to
have more torque so this is really
showing that as the student applies
larger and larger masses right over here
we're going to have more and more and
more torque
now what is in our vertical axis right
over here omega sub f divided by t so
this is our final angular velocity once
this thing has gone down a distance d
that's what they tell us divided by the
time it took to get there
well if we assume that it started from a
standstill you could view this as your
angular acceleration
so this is the angular acceleration as a
function of applied torque so i could
write angular acceleration right over
there or you could say your average
or you could say your average angular
acceleration over that time period from
when you start to time t
so what do we think would happen
well if you have small masses here it
would it would create a small torque but
if you have considerable friction which
they talk about right over here there's
considerable friction between the axle
and pulley so for small masses right
over here the torque will likely not be
strong enough to overcome the friction
and in that situation you would not have
any angular acceleration everything
would just stay still but then at some
point once your mass gets large enough
right over here then your torque will be
large enough to overcome the friction in
between the axle and the pulley so which
of these graphs describe that
or which of these plots
well this first one describes a
situation when you have a low applied
torque you have a high angular
acceleration that does not make sense so
we should rule that out
this one kind of shows angular
acceleration is indifferent to applied
torque and that doesn't make sense the
more applied torque you have the larger
mass is here well then you should have
more angular acceleration so that
doesn't make sense
now both of these show an upward trend
where as you have more applied torque
you have more angular acceleration so
which of these would you pick
well this one here on the right this
kind of paints a picture that as soon as
you have any applied torque you start
having angular acceleration and if this
was a frictionless system if there was
very little friction here maybe this
would make sense but as we talked about
for low masses which would generate
which have low weight so it would
generate low applied torque it wouldn't
be able to overcome friction and so you
should not have some angular
acceleration for low torques but then as
the torque gets larger you will overcome
the friction and then start to
accelerate the system
and so i would pick b